Tereza may still in office but just how
much power does she have the election
she called that she promised not to
delivered not the thumping majority she
sought but in fact no majority at all a
humiliation but one nonetheless that
lets her keep her job for now that was
what the Constitution the cabinet manual
requires in a hung parliament the
incumbent Prime Minister who feels they
can command the confidence of the
Commons can go to her majesty and ask
the former government having secured the
largest number of votes and the greatest
number of seats in the general election
it is clear that only the conservative
and unionist party has the legitimacy
and ability to provide that certainty by
commanding a majority in the House of
Commons this will allow us to come
together as a country and channel our
energies towards a successful brexit
deal that works for everyone in this
country securing a new partnership with
the EU which guarantees our long-term
prosperity that's what people voted for
last June that's what we will deliver
now let's get to work you'd be forgiven
for thinking she'd won a record majority
rather than having lost the one won by
David Cameron just two years ago
indeed the PM did incessantly make this
point on the campaign trail if we lose
just six seats then the government loses
its majority and here are the numbers we
are saying the Conservatives are on 340
and yet the exit poll confirmed it was
many more than six seats lost a
staggering surprise that silenced
Conservative HQ though he didn't win the
election Jeremy Corbyn did hit the mark
the triumph on the night and in the
campaign taking the seats of Cabinet
ministers even the author of mrs. Mays
manifesto ben Gummer arriving in
Maidenhead it was unclear if the Prime
Minister could last the night are you
gonna resign Prime Minister
mr. Corben the man who we were told
would lead his party into the abyss made
considerable progress we energizing
young voters and non voters against a
lackluster conservative campaign we put
forward our policies strong and hopeful
policies and they've gained an amazing
response and traction I think it's
pretty clear who won this election so
you should be born in this done we're
ready to serve the people who have given
their trust to us nice to see you this
morning
vindication for Jeremy Corbyn in
particular his acceptance of brexit but
not enough at this stage to form a
government along the way
hey that's partly down to a shock hit to
the SNP losing twenty one of their 56
seats on a conservative surge but the
Scottish First Minister aiming fire on
the PM with others if it is at all
possible to keep the Tories out of
government Tim Farron also claimed to be
a winner up for seats but not quite a
surge he went on the attack to Theresa
May promised strong and stable
leadership
she has brought weakness and uncertainty
if she has an ounce of self-respect she
will resign and as is now traditional
the leader of you Kip resigned
you keep caught in 18 months time be
bigger in terms of poll ratings and
members than it ever has been before
however it will not be with me as its
leader all eyes on Northern Ireland's
Democratic Unionist Party 10 seats to
help get the Tories over the line but
not without their own controversies no
deal just yet the Prime Minister has
spoken with me this morning and we will
enter discussions with the Conservatives
to explore how it may be possible to
bring stability to our nation cereza
Mays gamble failed spectacularly but she
also got the tone of her podium
statement wrong she didn't acknowledge
that young people had turned out in
historic proportions against the
Conservatives and that voters had
rejected her plea for a strengthened
brexit mandate so we got enough
more contrite statement after the
Downing Street staff applauded the PM
back home I'm sorry for all those
candidates and hard-working party
workers who weren't successful but also
particularly sorry for those colleagues
who were MPs and ministers who'd
contributed so much to our country and
who lost their seats and didn't deserve
to lose their seats and as I reflect on
the results I will reflect on what we
need to do in the future
her first job no change to the big five
cabinet positions with the Chancellor
home foreign brexit and defense
secretaries reappointed not a sign of
strength but the reality of a PM
boxed-in requiring total loyalty from
all her MPs as she seeks to pass a
Queen's speech and then launch difficult
brexit negotiations with a weaker hand
that Europe is well aware of as the PM
herself might say it's going to be
bloody difficult Faisal Islam Sky News
in Downing Street